hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein richtig tolles
der und zwar mache ich einen schoko
kugel mit eis runter und später kann man
da so eine leckere soße darüber geben
und dann geht die kugel auf sie hat es
bestimmt alle schon mal auf facebook
oder auf youtube oder irgendwo mal
gesehen nur gibt es eben keine richtigen
anleitung dazu deswegen dachte ich mache
ich das jetzt einfach mal vor allen
dingen ist es ein dessert für zwei das
heißt ihr könnt es zum beispiel auch
sobald dienstag machen oder einfach mal
so um jemanden zu überraschen denn ich
finde der effekt ist richtig toll wenn
die schokolade zerschmilzt und unten
dann dieses eis hervorkommt deswegen
zeigen wir jetzt ganz schön heißt ganz
schnell ich zeige euch jetzt wie das
funktioniert schnell jetzt nicht ihr
solltet euch auf jeden fall viel zeit
nehmen
zuerst müssen wir jetzt diesen
schokoladen hohlkörper die schoko kugel
herstellen und dafür habe ich mich jetzt
für weiße kuvertüre entschieden
ich habe jetzt hier 400 gramm das reicht
dann für vier kugeln ich habe jetzt hier
zwei drittel abgefüllt und hier ein
drittel und es bereits gehackt und dann
braucht ihr auch auf jeden fall noch
diese kugel und zwar sind die jetzt aus
dem aus der bastel abteilung vom globus
die gibt bestimmt auch in jedem
bastelgeschäft und zwar sind es so ich
glaube so christbaum problem sogar so
die kugeln wo man einfach was rein
füllen kann
die habe ich jetzt vorher gewaschen und
da habe ich jetzt eben vier stück und
die haben einen durchmesser von zehn
zentimetern so jetzt habe ich hier
bereits im wasserbad aufgestellt und
kann jetzt die zwei drittel kuvertüre
hier in der metall- schüssel geben und
das wasser war vorhin kurz aufgekocht
hab ich wieder ausgemacht
und jetzt kann ich das einfach hier kurz
darin schmelzen ihm ist halt auf jeden
fall darauf achten dass er die kuvertüre
temperiert und das mache ich jetzt eben
und wird die weiße kuvertüre auf etwa 29
30 grad temperierten
jetzt ist die kuvertüre geschmolzen
jetzt nehme ich sie vom topf herunter
und setzte jetzt runterkühlen mit dieser
restlichen ein dritter kuvertüre und es
ist wie ich schon mal gefragt ob die
impf methode die können jetzt im
thermometer nach kontrollieren aber muss
man nicht denn so ist es eigentlich
schon aufs grad genau also sobald die
jetzt geschmolzen ist ist sie so etwa
bei 129 30 grad
und sobald sie geschmolzen und
temperiert ist gebt ihr jetzt immer 100
gramm pro kugel in so eine halbkugel
hinein
und zwar habe ich das jetzt auch schon
öfter ausprobiert und habe geschaut
welche methode ist die beste damit es
immer funktioniert ohne dass die kugeln
später krachen und das ist wirklich am
besten ihr nehmt immer exakt 100 gramm
pro kugel dann ist nämlich einfach die
schokoladen wand dick genug und sie
bricht dann eben später nicht zumindest
dann kommt da der deckel drauf und kann
sein dass ihr das vielleicht mit seinen
thesen fixieren müsst denn die kugeln
die sich eigentlich nicht für so ein
küchen bedarf gedacht und sie jetzt
nicht so stabil und damit die einfach
jetzt nicht aufgehen während im rollen
klebe ich sie lieber noch mal zu
jetzt müsst ihr schokolade ganz gut
verteilen
jetzt muss die kuvertüre darin richtig
gleichmäßig fest werden damit die
schokoladen man einfach gleichmäßig dick
wird
und die beste möglichkeit für mich weil
es hier einfach so kräutler
tiefgekühltes gemüse zu nehmen und die
kugel draufzusetzen
jetzt trägt sie einfach ab und so ein
bisschen und danach geht es zuerst in
den gefrierschrank mache ich noch die
restlichen drehte hier kurz und dann
kommen sie in den gefrierschrank für
etwa eine stunde das ist auch ganz
wichtig denn dann löst sich dieser
schokoladen mantel also die kugel ganz
von alleine von diesem von diesem
plastik und dann kann man es eben
einfach herausholen
jetzt ist die kugel fertig und massiert
jetzt auch von außen dass sie sich
bereits von diesem von dieser
plastikschale gelöst hat und zwar war ja
vorher die kugel ziemlich gelb also man
hat die schokolade ganz weit außen
gesehen und sie dass es sich jetzt eben
zusammen gezogen hat und zusammen
also weg von der schale ist wenn ich's
tesa weg oder ich schmeiße entwurf jetzt
trotzdem ganz vorsichtig öffnen
und dann könnt ihr die kugel so lösen
und wenn ihr eben nicht lange genug
wartet und die kugel fest werden lassen
dann zerspringen solch ein fach und
deswegen lass das einfach im gefrierfach
lange genug also mindestens eine stunde
und dann funktioniert es auch von ganz
alleine
die kugeln habe ich jetzt einfach mal
zur seite gestellt und kann jetzt schon
mal die restlichen zutaten richten und
zwar werde ich jetzt eine leckere
karamellsoße mal und die brauchen wir
auch also wir brauchen eine warme soße
um die eben später drüber zu gießen
ich reichte dazu ein pistazien eis und
ich zeige mich was ich noch dazu reicht
also für die karamellsoße brauche ich
100 gramm zucker 50 milliliter wasser
150 milliliter sahne etwas vanille
extrakt mit prise salz 1 esslöffel
butter und dann reichlich eben noch fürs
alles wird dazu die habe ich jetzt
bereits klein geschnitten
ich hab hier werde ich noch ganz und in
der schale und ich habe nur ein paar
pistazien aber jetzt bereite ich erstmal
die karamellsoße zu und gebe jetzt den
zucker hier in einen topf und da kommt
das wasser mit rein gibt es auch direkt
die prise salz mit dazu und jetzt lasse
ich das erst einmal aufkochen und dann
so lange kochen bis diese bis der sirup
karamell farben ist es daher darauf
achten dass er nicht zu dunkel wird weil
er ansonsten bleibt peter wird
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal die tasche packen jetzt mal nicht so
viele
es ist neue gold pistazien
jetzt gebe ich noch etwas vanille
extrakt mit der zug den geschmack und
dann gebe ich die zimmer warme butter
mit rein natürlich ganz vorsichtig und
jetzt auch noch das stückchen butter
jetzt muss es einfach nur noch eine
minute etwa kochen und dann ist die soße
fertig
jetzt kann ich alles zu einem anrichten
und zwar nämlich erzählt dass pistazien
eis das ist so eine konditorei richtig
gut und ich vergesse den 1 laufen heiß
zu machen
aber es geht gerade dafür wie es braucht
zwei kugeln übereinander
da wäre es doch stehen bleiben jetzt
muss er noch eine öffnung in dieser
schokoladen kugel und zwar habe ich da
jetzt eine pfanne erhitzt und wieder
ausgemacht
jetzt nehme ich das aber am besten mit
einem ca jetzt kann ich diese hier unten
so eine öffnung einschmelzen am gefahren
ist sollte unbedingt aus sein musst du
aufpassen es geht ziemlich schnell
und jetzt setze ich die kugel hier drauf
und jetzt hab' da erstmal so die kunst
struktur im dekoriere ich das jetzt
schon mal mit casall ist und mit
pistazien islam ein tolles foto
das ist jetzt ein thema nicht deines
unglaublich oder
da stimmt doch was nicht fast so schön
um wahr zu sein ja ich glaub es gar
nicht was ich heute nicht mehr vor ist
aufmerksamer vom hochzeitstag
geburtstagen das kunststück hat alles
gut so und somit das wird auch
vorbereitend fällt jetzt viel gäste habt
bis dahin
und dann bringt es an den tisch und am
tisch kommt dann mit karamellsoße
darüber also murat passt auf ich mach
das jetzt nur einmal für dich ist für
für angeber
das ist etwas für angeben für blender
der richtige moment für mich
und jetzt
das sieht wirklich nur am anfang gut
aussah nachricht und macht spaß ein
bisschen wie karamellsoße morata ich
weiß du magst arena kamen
ich finde nur dass das erreicht auf
jeden fall für zwei personen also ich
finde allein kann man so ein riesen
teller nicht essen ich schau sommer ist
dagegen eine woche lang nichts mehr
aber im prinzip kann es jetzt nur gut
schmecken wenn man nimmt an eis seiner
wahl ich hätte pistazie genommen auch
als farblich gut zusammenpasst ich habe
fürs alles genommen weil einfach die
recht säuerlich sind und man einfach
nicht so ein papst diesen teller hat und
das weiße schock in die weiße schokolade
sei relativ süße darf ich jetzt ohne
spaß
also ich kann nicht erinnern dass ich
jemals so gute nachricht es noch weil
die pistazien kennedy physalis unten das
eis und schokolade dem wahnsinns- kombi
möglich auch sally du bist in der
nächsten runde
ich gratuliere dir da geht es nicht mehr
lustig aber ich finde es auch sehr gut
und es ist wirklich total lecker und
alles passt perfekt zusammen
vor allem die physalis sie bringen da
echt so ein bisschen noch diese säure
rhein und die haben diese kleinen kerne
schmeckt richtig gut
ja also wenig dass dieser nach machen
wollt müsst auf jeden fall viel geduld
mitnehmen und das mit den kugeln also
das dauert eine weile aber ich finde so
wenn man mal jemanden überraschen möchte
dann lohnt sich auf jeden fall ihr
solltet ihr immer die kamera mitlaufen
lassen die handykamera ich finde sich
was was man immer mit aufnehmen muss und
wenn ihr das nachmacht dann freue ich
mich falls er zum beispiel ein kleines
video macht es auf instagram hochladen
dann schaue ich mir das gerne mal an das
rezept gibt es zum nachlesen und mit
allen tipps nochmal auf zehn.de und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
zusammen
superkombi wir waren zum ersten mal zum
ersten date der mcdonald's